and we are approaching the last few days
of the legislative session Republican
Governor Joe Lombardo has vetoed two
dozen bills passed by the
democrat-controlled legislature they
include a bill that would have limited
the length of trains a bill that kept
rent increases for seniors with fixed
incomes a requirement for master plan
communities to include heat mitigation
plans and a part of a budget that paid
for a wide variety of things from
funding courts museums and programs like
foster care Lombardo said that used
one-time money to fund long-term
programs Democrats need a republican to
go along with any veto overrides the
session ends on Monday night